how you feeling nina here huh I know
you're hot but how you feeling so lesson
learned don't walk in the bike lane
what's up Nina huh I believe in you Nina
Nina hasn't seen me yet she's gonna be
really surprised
[Music]
[Music]
we are walking to find a Starbucks to
sit down enjoy coffee it's gonna be our
last Starbucks for two days because
tomorrow is the day SC so we're
following our directions what are you
gonna get no I think walking the right
way I have a internal GPS we know where
we're going what are you gonna get a
warm drink our cold warm uh oh I felt
the drop me and I felt the job now okay
good okay let's find their Starbucks go
oh ho look what we found
good job Nina and they have pumpkin
spice and she we're gonna order
done with Starbucks while we're still
drinking but we're gonna head off to st.
Michael's Church where you can climb up
the tower to get to the top and have a
view of the city we'll see how it goes
with this rain but excited to check it
out last stop before heading back to the
cruise ship
[Music]
[Music]
all right time to climb the stairs to
the top 5022 told the joke dude it's not
5022
I totally made that up penis 5000 nobody
serious 5022 it beeped me crazy
[Applause]
we've only done like 30 of the 5000
something stairs in Minnesota maybe a
little faster
you think you're at the top but you're
not keep going inna keep going this does
not count as you work out for the day by
the way keep going well here's the belt
look at the Bell
that means Ramos there you got it Nina
you got this what's up Nina huh I
believe in you Nina 5000 stairs like a
high up we are like the buildings
outside
who she comes this is the last set go
Nina oh not quite the last chef
almost almost
hello Nina I know I said the last one
was the last one but because I see the
last one I accept that you want to go up
there
good job high five boom welcome to
Hamburg maybe to the top almost what
that's pretty good
Lena's legs are burning you like those
five thousand steps that's pretty cool
up there though I'm glad we went okay
next home find the subway we're not
going to walk that great find the subway
and get back to the cruise all right
Nina made an executive decision she
wants to walk back so we've got how long
40 minutes 45 minutes 40 minutes of the
stairs I like it hopefully it doesn't
rain get some solid weather and we get
our steps and you have a lot of subsidy
Nina will do an official count once you
get back in the book all right
onwards to the cruise
[Applause]
so they have bike planes everywhere here
but it's really hard to see so I'm going
to Exxon's check it out here there's a
difference in the brick this brown brick
is the bike lane this regular brick is
the walking Lane so it's not super clear
where the bike lane is and where you're
supposed to walk and Nina and I both
almost got hit by cyclists today so
lesson learned don't walk in the bike
lane
[Music]
how you feeling nina here huh I know
you're hot but how you feeling
lightheaded okay so don't go on the boat
and start drinking okay
Oh time for an ice shower when we go
home ice tower let's go all right keep
walking
[Music]
oh my goodness
what did we find in us what did we find
looks like our boats very very very very
exciting we are almost here Xena we made
it through phases we mated alright we
are back on the boat
we are happy we are a little tired we're
gonna go to the room
and what chill out for a little bit
relax can we sit down and then get ready
to eat
although neither of us are hungry right
now but I think little water getting
that into us he'll be ready to go for
dinner soon
[Music]
okay Nina step count how many steps did
we do today thirty almost thirty three
thousand that's pretty good and we're
not even done yet high five
boom Japanese Wow when you did that you
shook the camera such force don't mess
with Nina in her high fives
[Music]
all right so I had a shower because my
feet were really smelly because after
30,000 steps of walking in five to shoes
where your socks get wet it gets pretty
smelly so I decided to shower and do the
shave nina hasn't seen me yet she's
gonna be really surprised so I thought
I'd show you guys first the new huh huh
what do we think friends what do we
think how is it good do we like it let's
see Nina's reaction okay you happy
got the shave on oh all right okay
everybody wins and I've never seen you
so happy you have her trying new food
and she's she's like yeah yeah just
shave a little bit but you see the beard
allows you to appreciate the shape face
it was this every day you hit you get
used to it and then you wouldn't be
happy so boom all right for you happy
vacation
all right so getting used to the new
face okay well we are all cleaned up
we're gonna go downstairs
we're gonna go for dinner I'm not really
hungry but yeah it's gonna be crazy
everybody's gonna get back on the boat
and go to dinner and last time we waited
long we were the last to be served and
took forever so we're gonna try to get
there literally or though I think it's
still gonna be a line up we'll see
probably gonna eat little lights not
that have a beer just have some water
and enjoy some food
Nina's hungry no all right well when
you're not hungry it's important to go
to dinner and then go eat dessert at the
buffet
[Music]
the Filipino bartender asked me nephews
Filipino
are you Filipina
what do you think the legation does Nina
Filipina but she just lied to me she's
Chinese
she really a Filipino Filipino okay not
a Filipino that is scary that's really
that's a big lie then whatever you are
we love you and your kids okay that was
a pretty big smile
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right boat is leaving we're being
pulled out we just have a good dinner
I'm feeling pretty good I had two
desserts he was feeling very stuffed
yeah so we're gonna head back up to the
[Music]
okay we're gonna break that Nina's gonna
work out guys when you know what you
need to do when you have clear focus you
gotta push as hard as you can push as
hard as you can while you have your
focus you don't know what you're doing
it's okay explore you try things up but
with you know push as hard as you can
cuz that window is gonna close it was my
reign for the day
holding on to me
well then I get on the treadmill Nina's
gonna get in the check mill all right my
piece
let's see if we get a towel anyone today
they're gonna pay that you know
[Music]
so we were supposed to leave like a
couple hours ago but they make - just
lined up all the cruise ships that were
leaving Hamburg at the same time and
they scheduled them and now they put on
this firework show so that was the
firework show from my boat which is
awesome and I'm gonna show you the
lineup of all the cruise ships behind me
and in front so there's one in front of
us and then there's us and then if I
scroll around they'll see that there's
another behind and there's another
behind and I think another even behind
says like five different cruise ships
here and it's a pretty cool thing to get
known for right I'm always looking at
business models it's cool to know that
when you go to Hamburg there's gonna be
a firework show it's a blast off to
celebrate the people that have come it
makes the cruise ships delay their
itinerary right like we're supposed to
leave at 8:00 and it's all like 10:00 so
waited two extra hours just so that we
could line up the boats to give the show
to the audience and it's a you know free
thing for the cruise ships and for the
passengers and put on by the city of
Hamburg and it's a really cool thing
like it makes people want to come back
and make Saku ships want to come back
they made a special announcement saying
guys check out on the left sides not the
left side whatever the C C term is port
side check it out because they're gonna
do it and so I'm always thinking from a
business perspective or entrepreneurship
or even on a city level what can you do
that makes people want to come back that
stands out that gets noticed because
we've been to all these different cities
none of them did something like this oh
now they're starting to put the boat
behind right that's going on for these
behind this down right it's like what
can you do what can you do to come back
to your business
could you guys hear that cheer and after
you hear the cherry I want that you your
business I want you to the Hamburg
there's at least five cruise ships that
are here that are leaving tonight
that delayed the itinerary that made a
point to come here to Hamburg where
every other city that we've been to it's
been like one other cruise ship no
cruise ships to cruise ships there's at
least five cruise ships here and yes
that put you know that cost the city
some money to put on way to cost them
some money but you've got five cruise
ships at least has ten thousand plus
people coming to your city investing
money spending cash propping up the
businesses that are here it's worth it
just a quick fireworks show and thank
the people for coming out right here the
horns cruise ship saying thank you I
want that for your business what's that
in your business what's the firework
show to say thank you to your customers
so that they want to come back every
single time and I love it make that
happen
be the Hamburg
[Music]
all right Nina's back from her workout
how'd you do any man yeah ten thousand
steps and now it work out 600 calories
nice now we're gonna head up to the 12th
deck and check out the food Nina Nina
deserve that she earned it I did too
I did some good book work and then I
went on a y'all you missed my rent I
went on a huge rant about fireworks it's
good you know we passed a lion king
thing again you know we stayed here we
stayed here for like two hours yeah yeah
we left at 8:00 and it's 10:00 we stayed
here for two hours just to line up the
boats to do that parade to watch the
fireworks two hours
see that's the power be like Hamburg
guys okay this is the moment of truth
what what it do they have rhubarb do
they have a gumball what do they have
it's a Linzer tart
[Music]
that's that let done I don't think I
looks too dry to put anything like all
right just ice cream very sad Nina's
looking on the positive side of things I
appreciate that man that's a lot of
cookies Nina what cookies with fried
chicken wings
yeah I'm still upset about whatever that
gross thing is instead of my I went to
go get a soup bowl for my ice cream
because people
[Music]
Nina that's not how you do ice cream
okay okay this is not how you do ice
cream when I show you guys it's not
coming in next time guys give me some
quality strawberry rhubarb or apple
crumble blueberry crumble all right all
right all right back to the room to
relax all right
11:40 about to wrap up for the night got
the page 280 of 428 moving on to Dave
Grohl he's got an awesome story
so 280 let's see how much progress I can
make tomorrow it's a day at sea so
hopefully can get some good work done
that's what I got for you guys today
thank you for joining me on another fun
life with Evan episode we had a great
time in Hamburg they'd see tomorrow then
London then back to Toronto back to work
I love it
hope you had an amazing weekend I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon